et vous en france est-ce que vous avez
respecté mes consignes du ministre de
l'intérieur qui a renforcé les contrôles
ce week-end je vous le rappelle pas plus
de 6 même dehors bien on vous a posé la
question à paris regardez alors la règle
des six personnes à l'intérieur je la
comprends parce qu'il ya un problème des
rsa mais à l'extérieur c'est vrai que je
comprends pas trop sachant que
après je comprends parce que
c'est surtout pour les apéros enfin les
moments où on n'a pas le masque
[Musique]
e
mais en même temps
en fait si on l'a contournée c'est vrai
que c'est très facile si on a un groupe
de douze ont fait europe 2,6 et on va
donner un autre
en fait j'ai l'impression que ces
mesures prises sont prises par des
personnes qui ne savent pas vraiment ce
que c'est en fait à l'abri mais qui font
jamais ça aide qui seront pas contents
fait
qui es tu
mesures à prendre plus logique en fait
non je ne comprends pas forcément et je
n'ai pas forcément respectée non plus
déjà chez moi on est on est une famille
nombreuse et on sort tous on a tous nos
vies donc le fait de se rassembler en
extérieur à -2 si c'est parfois
compliqué et au delà de ça bah moi j'ai
fait du sport ce week-end et olé qui
était bondé les gens se croiser et on
était bien plus de 6 c'était même
parfois des passages difficiles
donc non je la comprends pas pas du coup
alors je la comprends d'une certaine
façon moi je pense que un groupe de six
personnes
ça permet de rester dans un groupe
raisonnée qui à mon avis peu respecté
les règles de barrières sanitaires
après est-ce que c'est facile à
à respecter
je dirais qu'en ce moment comme il
commence à refaire beau etc c'est un
petit peu compliqué on voit quand même
beaucoup de gens dehors mais tout le
monde a envie de respirer et c'est vrai
que c'est un petit peu difficile je
trouve que nous c'est une responsabilité
individuelle comprend chacune
individuellement se dit bon ben ok bah
si on doit aussi on doit payer 135 euros
on leur a en tout cas même mérité parce
qu'on ne respecte pas la règle est ce
qu'on comprend là elle oui pourquoi 6,7
enfin c'est un peu c'est complètement
arbitraire en fait pourquoi si c'est pas
là dessus c'est sûr que c'est un peu
plus incompréhensible alors j'imagine
qu'il ya des questions médicales
derrière avec le r0 rouge pourquoi mais
mais c'est vrai que le chiffre me semble
très arbitraire alors
je respecte pas vraiment cette règle e
parce que c'est compliqué
le sport quand
on est jeune à paris et qu'on a pas mal
d'amis c'est difficile de limiter juste
à 6 d'autant plus que
travail je vois plus de six personnes je
vois pas pourquoi je continuerai
j'appliquerai une règle que j'applique
pas forcément au travail ou même pour me
déplacer
ouais non je comprends pas forcément
logique de cette loi mais je trouve que
depuis le départ finalement le
gouvernement et pas forcément très clair
sur les décisions qui prend je fais mon
mieux parfois c'est un peu difficile ont
été invités aux choses avec des amis et
ouais pas forcément dé renom en plus ça
fait tellement longtemps que l'on n'a
pas vu des gens donc ouais ça ça donne
envie d'aller voir des potes et tous
danser c'est difficile je fais le
maximum de le faire mais ça m'arrive de
ne pas le respecter mais j'avoue qu'on
extérieur j'ai un peu plus de mal à
comprendre parce que c'est beaucoup plus
facile de respecter les distanciation
social on peut se retrouver à plus
en respectant le les gestes barrière est
effectivement par exemple je fais du
sport dans le score à clermont et à plus
de 6 dans les équipes pour jouer
ensemble et c'est pas pour ça qu'on
prend forcément des risques donc
et le seul choses très basiques on
comprend pas trop c'est pourquoi si ça
sort d'où voilà